oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous protéger ses nous protéger face à
la mondialisation protéger nos
agriculteurs protéger nos commerçants
protéger notre économie
protégé s'est également engagé des
français face à l'immigration massive
l'immigration incontrôlée nous protéger
face à l'insécurité au quotidien ip lait
français pour moi c'est libérer les
entreprises enfin pour le rapport ce
soient les contraintes administratives
juridiques financières mais cela nous de
l'énergie il est dynamique et pour
capitaliser là dessus il faut simplifier
casser ce millefeuille administratif et
rendre l'entrepreneuriat accessible
libérer pour moi c'est faire confiance
faire confiance à nos entreprises et à
nos jeunes entrepreneurs qui sont
l'avenir de la france faire confiance
aussi à nos jeunes agriculteurs et à nos
industriels en les libérant des
contraintes inhérentes environnemental
car on aura besoin d'eux aussi pour
élever les et des filles du changement
climatique rassembler pour moi c'est
pour ça la culture la culture n'est pas
l'apanage de la gauche à droite on peut
aussi faire de la culture un cendrier
français pour le fait souvent histoire
des valeurs communes on a un super pays
qui a une super histoire alors gras sont
bons les français
[Musique]
le
je vous demande à présent d'accueillir
deux parlementaires qui vont vous faire
la présentation de notre projet celui
des républicains olivier marleix ex vice
président du mouvement et député
d'eure-et-loir et je commence par la fin
par le meilleur notre collègue sénatrice
des hauts-de-seine christine lagarde que
je vous demande d'applaudir
[Musique]
à
chers amis toutes les règles de
distanciation sont cruels
malheureusement
notre notre responsabilité est immense
vous qui êtes la jeunesse d'avenir de
notre mouvement politique
souvenez vous que vous êtes
les héritiers les dépositaires d'une
vision exigeante de la france cette
vision sur celle du général de gaulle
celle de georges pompidou seul du
président giscard d'estaing celle de
jacques chirac et celle de nicolas
sarkozy avec eux
et à chaque moment de notre histoire
notre mouvement a su incarner
transmettre et renouvelé notre vision de
la france nous avons aujourd'hui la
lourde responsabilité la tâche exaltante
de renouer le fil de cette histoire de
l'histoire de la droite de l'histoire de
la france alors pour élaborer ce projet
notre méthode
notre recette a été élaboré par le chef
christian jacob à partir de 5 5
ingrédients
le premier d'abord ça a été c'est
l'humilité
cela fera bientôt dix ans que nous ne
gouvernons plus la france est après deux
échecs consécutifs à l'élection
présidentielle nous avons un devoir
d'humilité et nous avons surtout le
devoir de nous remettre nous avions le
devoir de nous remettre au travail pour
convaincre les français
le deuxième ingrédient c'est justement
le travail
les propositions de ce projet que vous
avez entre les mains ce sont le fruit
d'un long travail mené depuis janvier
2020 à l'initiative de christian parent
du sport mêlant acteurs
socio-économiques professionnels élus
locaux élus nationaux
des forums qui ont tenu près de 200 plus
de 200 réunions de travail qui ont
auditionné une centaine d'experts sans
compter la quarantaine que nous avons
rencontrés avec christine depuis
et qui ont débouché sur douze
conventions thématiques le troisième
élément c'est l'ancrage
l'ancrage local en deux ans nous avons
gagné les élections municipales les
élections sénatoriales cher gérard
larcher cher bruno les élections
départementales et évidemment les
régionales soyons fiers d'être le
premier parti de france en nombre d'élus
locaux et notre projet ce n'est pas un
produit concocté en chambre par quelques
technocrates parisiens
c'est véritablement le produit de ce qui
fait notre marque de fabrique ce qui
fait notre adn le ce que nos élus locaux
ressens-tu nous font remonter depuis le
terrain sur les attentes des français
quatrième élément la fidélité et
fidélité envers nos militants notre
méthode était fondée sur la mobilisation
de nos militants qui ont été invités
convention après convention a approuvé à
débattre autour de ses propositions et
elles sont généralement reçu un appui
massif de nos militants qui se sont
exprimées parfois par dizaines de
milliers à l'occasion de ces de ces
conventions et enfin unité unité un mot
qui n'est jamais inutile de rappeler à
chaque question ce projet est surtout la
preuve qu'il existe au sein des
républicains un puissant souffle d'idée
que ce qui nous rassemble est beaucoup
plus fort que si qui peut parfois nous
diviser sur l'essentiel nous faisons le
même diagnostic et nous arrivons aux
mêmes propositions pour la france
alors pour quelle raison avant nous une
responsabilité aussi importante en 2022
et bien tout simplement parce que
emmanuel macron n'a pas fait le travail
qu'attendait de lui les français et que
nous sommes les seuls aujourd'hui à
proposer à projet d'alternatives
crédibles
regardons les faits de manière
dépassionnée et lucide
emmanuel macron at-il fait les 60
milliards d'euros d'économies pour
réduire les impôts de 20 milliards comme
il l'avait promis
la réponse est non
les dépenses publiques et les
prélèvements obligatoires n'ont pas
cessé n'ont pas baissé depuis 2016
énoncés et il n'a pas non plus baisser
les effectifs de 120 mille
fonctionnaires comme il l'avait dit mais
il a même réussi à recréer des emplois
dans la fonction publique emmanuel
macron at il rendu notre économie plus
compétitive comme il s'y était engagé
pendant sa campagne non la france
enregistré en 2020 le plus grand déficit
commercial d'europe le plus grand
déficit commercial de son histoire
65 milliards d'euros de déficit 65
milliards d'euros de déficit sont 65
milliards de salaire de dividendes que
nous payons à l'étranger et nous avons
perdu avec emmanuel macron vous le savez
des fleurons industriels de premier rang
comme alcatel ou alstom
emmanuel macron at il rendu la justice
efficace en faisant appliquer 100% des
peines prononcées et en construisant les
15000 places de prison qu'il avait
promises n'ont jamais les peines de
prison n'était aussi peu appliquée
seulement 54% des peines de prison sont
appliquées dans notre pays six mois
après la condamnation les 15000 places
de prisons promise par emmanuel macron
n'ont jamais vu le jour à peine 2000
supplémentaires ont été ouvertes depuis
le début du quinquennat et la moitié des
amendes pénales dans notre pays ne sont
pas recouvré
emmanuel macron at-il fait exécuter 100
% des décisions d'expulsion
comme il l'avait promis dans valeurs
actuelles pour faire plaisir sans doute
aux lecteurs de cet hebdomadaire
la réponse est évidemment non jamais les
décisions d'expulsions n'ont été aussi
peu appliquée dans notre pays seulement
une sur huit en 2019 et il y encore sur
notre sol presque 4000 étrangers fiché
pour radicalisation à caractère
terroriste sans parler de l'immigration
qui franchi des records
avec en terme de titre de séjour ou en
nombre de demandeurs d'asile et surtout
emmanuel macron at-il rassembler les
français pour relever notre nation non
il a fracturé tout au long de son
quinquennat notre pays en opposant les
français en affichant son mépris pour
les petites communes où nos compatriotes
sont contraints de prendre leur
automobile pour aller travailler c'est
une réalité que le président macron
semble un semblez méconnaître tout au
long de son quinquennat en affichant son
mépris des corps intermédiaires et du
parlement cher gérard larcher
transformer le plus souvent d'une simple
chambre d'enregistrement
en affichant son mépris de la culture
française qui selon lui n'existe pas ou
de notre histoire qui dit vouloir
reconstruire nos compatriotes attendent
donc de nous un proche des efforts pour
réparer notre pays pour rebâtir la
france pour rassembler les français
c'est je crois ce que contient
aujourd'hui le projet que vous nous
présentons dont vous allez débattre cet
après-midi et dont je vais laisser ma
collègue christine vous présenter les
principales propositions
merci
[Applaudissements]
merci olivier donc effectivement cet
avant projet qui sera amené à être a
évolué être approfondies par vos débats
cet après midi par les échanges qui
pourront voir avoir lieu en fédération
dans les semaines qui viennent avant
d'être voté par le congrès de notre
parti il est construit autour de trois
thèmes dont vous avez déjà entendu
parler protéger libérer et rassembler
alors bien évidemment ce projet ce n'est
pas un projet hors sol il a été
construit à partir du contexte que nous
venons de vivre à savoir une crise
sanitaire qui a conduit à une crise
économique à une crise sociale mais
surtout cette crise elles arrivent les
d'une part le déclin français et en même
temps des problèmes structurels vais
vous donner juste quelques exemples la
décision dans l'industrialisation
massive de notre pays n'a pas été
capable de remonter facilement des
chaînes de production de masques notre
dépendance vis-à-vis de la chine
aujourd'hui notre industrie automobile
ne peut plus livrer des véhicules car
nous n'avons pas de semi conducteurs
notre retard dans l'innovation et dans
la recherche nous sommes le seul pays
membre du conseil de sécurité de l'onu à
ne pas avoir développé un vaccin en
propre aujourd'hui la france ne doit
plus être la belle endormie
la france doit peut être le pays où il
fait bon vivre nous devons nous
réveiller et c'est ce que nous allons
essayer de vous proposer dans cet avant
projet alors tout d'abord un état qui
protège c'est un état fort c'est à dire
un état qui lutte contre l'insécurité
contre le terrorisme contre
l'immigration de masse mais c'est aussi
un état stratège pour notre souveraineté
et pour défendre nos intérêts vitaux
alors bien évidemment je vais pas
pouvoir vous développer toutes les
propositions qui figurent dans cet avant
projet j'ai juste envie de vous donner
envie de le lire le découvrir et après
avoir entendu les élus qui se sont
exprimés juste avant nous je sais déjà
qu'il répond à certaines de leurs
attentes et de leurs aspirations
alors qu'est ce que c'est qu'un état
fort dans cet avant projet c'est
notamment construire le plus vite
possible 20000 places de prison
supplémentaires
c'est supprimer les réductions de peines
automatiques ou les peines plancher pour
les récidivistes ou les délinquants qui
s'attaquent aux forces de l'ordre c'est
instaurer un plafond d'immigration
c'est créer un fonds souverain qui
permettrait de mobiliser l'épargné
défense et et d'investir dans les
secteurs stratégiques
c'est contrôler les investissements
étrangers mais bien évidemment un état
qui protège c'est aussi un état qui est
attentif à chaque français c'est à dire
un état qui ira vers les plus fragiles
d'entre nous notamment nous avons des
propositions pour adapter notre pays au
vieillissement de la population
nous avons des propositions pour que les
personnes handicapées ne se sentent plus
comme mis à côté de la société mais bien
inclus nous avons des propositions pour
les avancées dans la médecine notamment
un plan alzheimer le constat que nous
avons fait aujourd'hui c'est que l'état
est souvent trop faible
là où il devrait être fort et cal
inverse il est souvent trop lourd là où
il devrait être l'est et c'est là le
deuxième thème du projet c'est-à-dire
libérer la crise que nous avons vécue
elle nous a montré que nous avons
largement atteint les limites de l'état
centralisateur de l'état providence de
l'état qui est même parfois trop
tatillon il se concentre trop sur
l'accessoire et il ne va jamais à
l'essentiel et pour aller à l'essentiel
il nous semble qu'il faut vraiment faire
confiance à chacune des forces vives les
entrepreneurs les collectivités
territoriales notamment par des
transferts de compétences qui seront
accrues mais il faut aussi alléger
l'énorme un exemple étendre le pouvoir
de dérogation des préfets pour un motif
d'intérêt général il faut diminuer la
pression fiscale un exemple il faut
aller jusqu'à une division par deux des
impôts de production c'est-à-dire aller
beaucoup plus loin que ce qui a commencé
à être fait mais il faut aussi bien
évidemment réduire la bureaucratie pour
une meilleure efficacité de l'action
publique quelques exemples une
numérisation mais numérisation pour tous
pas une numérisation qui laisse certains
au bord du chemin il faut faire passer
la part du personnel dans les hôpitaux à
25%
c'est réalisable dans tout un tas
d'autres pays de l'union européenne ce
pourcentage est beaucoup plus faible
pour donner des véritables moyens aux
soignants et ne pas revivre les absurdie
que nous avons pu entendre pendant cette
crise sanitaire mais il faut aussi
libérer la france du surendettement
car agir ainsi c'est aussi rassembler
les français pour ne pas faire peser sur
les générations futures le poids de
notre incurie d'aujourd'hui et j'en
arrive au dernier thème justement
rassembler le coc vide a quand même
entraîné un repli sur soi de chacun il
nous faut aujourd'hui bâtir un projet
qui rassemble chaque français est un
projet qui rassemble c'est un projet qui
permet de partager une ambition commune
autour d'un projet de société alors ce
projet de société ce serait tout d'abord
récompensé le travail et l'effort
quelques exemples améliorer la
rémunération nette de tous les français
qui travaillent par une baisse de la csg
sur les revenus d'activité
c'est avoir des aides sociales qui sont
plafonnées à 75% du smic et qui sont
conditionnées à une activité d'intérêt
général ou à une véritable action de
formation pour retrouver le chemin de
l'emploi 1 ce projet de société c'est
rebâtir l'école de la république autour
de la transmission des savoirs
fondamentaux se concentrer sur
l'essentiel
mais rassembler c'est aussi et surtout
ne pas opposer les français les uns aux
autres et on l'a bien vu avec certaines
décisions de ce gouvernement notamment
en matière d'écologie aujourd'hui le
développement durable doit bien se
comprendre sur ces trois jambes c'est à
dire la protection de l'environnement le
développement économique et l'attention
aux autres c'est à dire le volet social
et c'est ce que nous vous proposons
notamment avec des efforts d
investissements dans la recherche dans
l'hydrogène ou dans la gestion des
déchets nucléaires plutôt qu'un
empilement de nouvelle mesure où de
nouvelles interdictions c'est une
décarbonation des transports avec un
massification du fret ferroviaire avec
un développement des biocarburants
plutôt que l'ajout de nouvelles taxes et
bien évidemment ce projet il n'est pas
hors sol il n'est pas construit comme ça
c'est aussi un projet qui est équilibré
alors je vais pas vous inonder de
chiffres mais en tout cas ce que nous
avons été très attentifs à faire avec
olivier c'est à chaque fois pendant
ponte des hypothèses de chiffrage que
certains qualifieront peut-être deux
de pessimistes à dire que sur la fraude
tout un tas de sujets pour qu'à la fin
depuis ce pas nous dire vous n'êtes pas
crédible non ce projet il tient il est
bouclé et pourquoi vous avez peut-être
entendu des dépenses mais nous avons
aussi un certain nombre de mesures qui
préconise des économies notamment
recentrant de l'action de l'état sur les
priorités budgétaires en introduisant
une véritable réforme des retraites ou
en luttant contre la fraude à
[Musique]
la jav charice y en a chez un ami à tous
ceux qui répètent en boucle sans doute
pour se re a pu se rassurer que la
droite ne travaillerait pas que la
droite n'aurait pas d'idée que la droite
n'aurait rien à proposer je vous invite
vraiment à brandir ce projet à sept mois
de sept mois de l'élection
présidentielle quels autres mouvements
politiques à présenter des propositions
aussi concrète aussi cohérente chiffrés
comme nous venons de le faire en marche
reproche régulièrement à l'opposition de
n'avoir ne pas faire des propositions
mais ils n'en font jamais aucune n'est
ce pas emmanuel macron lui-même
d'ailleurs qui avait déclaré je cite
entre guillemets se des
programmes et bien chez les républicains
on ne se fout pas des programmes car ce
serait se des français
ce qu emmanuel macron n'a pas réussi
depuis quatre ans qui peut croire qu'il
est réussir est dans les cinq prochaines
années quant à madame le pen elle
recycle éternellement les mêmes si des
simples avec la même un préparation
visible à exercer quelques pouvoirs que
ce soit responsable déterminé crédible
nous présentons français une feuille de
route pour à bâtir la france elle devra
évidemment à chaque question être
appropriée par notre candidat qui
disposent là en tout cas d'un socle de
propositions précises pour proposer son
propre projet aux français
c'est à nous que revient aujourd'hui
cette tâche d'offrir aux français des
raisons d'espérer dans leur avenir et
dans celui de leurs enfants dans le
sillon du général de gaulle ne céderons
jamais à l'école du renoncement
nationale à cet étrange passion de
l'abaissement relevant la tête
soyons fiers croyons toujours en nos
chances et ans est de la france